tercer intento pese a haber sido
devuelto ya dos veces desde polonia
belarús hadi un migrante iraquí insiste
cruzar hacia el territorio polaco y
desde allí continuar su camino hacia
otros países de la unión europea
los guardias fronterizos polacos nos
empujaron de regreso a belarús
no nos golpearon pero no nos dieron agua
ni comida alhama hola aquel a pesar de
las advertencias de las autoridades
polacas
y sus dos compañeros prefieren
esconderse en el bosque que ocupa gran
parte de los 400 kilómetros de la
frontera entre los dos países antes que
regresar a irak este grupo de
inmigrantes huye de la represión contra
la comunidad lg vehículos
institucionalizada en su país
soy parte de la comunidad lgtb y esto
está prohibido en irak tanto a nivel
social como jurídico
que allí te persiguen te matan no tienes
ningún derecho allá
ahora estos migrantes se enfrentan a una
atención persistente entre la unión
europea y belarús y es que la frontera
entre belarús y polonia se ha convertido
en un punto de entrada para miles de
migrantes provocando una crisis
migratoria el bloque europeo ha acusado
a mills por la gran afluencia de
migrantes como una provocación por parte
del gobierno de lukashenko por las
sanciones que le ha impuesto la unión
europea además a este complejo panorama
para los migrantes se le suma las
fuertes medidas restrictivas que ha
impuesto a polonia para controlar la
migración que tras declarar el estado de
emergencia ha enviado a miles de tropas
a la zona y ha construido una gran
columna de alambres